the thing that distinguishes 5g from the
previous what we've been doing is that
it doesn't tell you in advance how are
you gonna need what are you supposed to
use here as opposed to an exercise
that's headed the sign rule and you can
reasonably expect every question in that
exercise when we use the same rule here
is sort of now stepping back and saying
okay now you know all of this stuff one
of the skills that's being assessed is
okay can you actually work out what part
you're supposed to use not just be told
okay you're gonna have to use this find
a way to use it but okay I have all
these different tools at my disposal
which one should be my choice all right
so these are the three questions that
every time you're presented with these
triangles and angles and sides you're
going to post yourself okay so we start
off with the simplest one if we're going
right back to the beginning area is
where we begin and that's because it's
pretty straightforward
it's quite easy to work out if that's
what you're going for what you're going
to use what was the very first like
think back to you seven you if you saw a
triangle shut down a little bit and then
come back to reality um if you had to
find an area for a triangle you need two
things what are they basically very good
so if your trust fund area you know at
the base are high then you're going to
slot that into I should say Ames you're
going to slot that into the formula
which has the base indictment however
you might not having the basin height
probably triangle might not be right
angled or that kind of thing there's
another way that we've developed to work
out the area triangle but you need
different information what do you need
feedback the duct this is one of things
you don't have to rely on the right
angles you can go back to our earlier
table that we did on this let me help
you out we're still gonna need some size
two of them in fact but that in addition
to that you need a particular angle is
in order
it's the yeah the one that's between
them which we call the included angle if
you've got two sides and an included
angle then you can use area equals okay
so ever again start to the half correct
so there are your two sides and there is
your angle that's between the two sides
okay cool and that's really all that is
very yeah that's it okay what about
science about science
okay so if you've got a right-angled
triangle and you've got two sides so I
guess that I'm looking to that these two
sides and a right angle in your triangle
okay if it's a right angle triangle like
this right and you've got two sides like
these two you want a fiber side
what you doing is just gonna go to
Pythagoras right so you can just say a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
no trigonometry required just like here
but there are other ways to find sides
and the other way they used based on
what information that you have so for
instance thing if you've got again let's
see here
aside so you're after side you can see
you've already being given a sign in the
triangle and two matching angles by
matching I mean when you like opposite
the side that you want so the situation
you're thinking of is okay here is some
random triangle no right angles required
here's a side you want to know and what
you've been provided is another one of
the sides like say this one and then
you've got two matching anglers so in
this case where would I have to position
the angles to be useful to me
yeah opposite X and opposite end very
good so here's the one opposite X and
here's the one that's opposite n if
you've got that what information came
this is a sine rule okay so what does
the sine rule look like if you're trying
to find sine you can say a on what's
that equal to okay and you can see I've
set up to help me find a sign as fast as
possible because beside that I want is
right there the top left point is is to
multiply to be my sine a and I'm done
whatever happens to be you know is it
all right now you can sometimes find a
sign if you know even more than that if
you think back to this fancy way that we
use the Pythagoras theorem and then we
expanded it if you don't have a right
angle so instead of having two sides and
then a degrees or a sign as to measure
angles if you have two sides and the
included angle so that's the same idea
that I've got up here right two sides
and an included angle I'm running out of
space on me so this is what I've got
I've got a distance over here like say
11 centimeters another let's make that
shorter nine centimeters
where's thing for table Timmy Twitter to
the bottom left right so if you got this
one over here what information can be
okay so I'll use Pythagoras I'm sorry
really the only one we have left is to
co-sign me what does it look like when
you are trying to find it it's very
similar to this one it's got these
cutting agents yeah
a squared plus B CH bit so it starts
just like Pythagoras and then another
you wanna put it yet break - to a me
cause see okay yeah so this is why we're
putting it all together so you can see
here it's very similar to this one but
it's like well you know what if it's not
90 degrees if you've got an included
angle you're fine you can still find
sorry that's a big mess okay so if
you've gotta find area there's these two
ways you're gonna find sides depending
on the information we've got these three
wait lastly what's the final feature if
you're searching the angles okay so if
it's a right angle triangle and you've
got say yeah two sides and ninety
degrees it's just like here so that was
silly huh whistles quick that if you've
got two sides and 90 degrees it's a
right angle triangle what can you use to
find say I don't know this able up here
what would you use in that case okay
it's just a right angle triangle so you
go back to sohcahtoa so in this case the
two sides you're looking for are
adjacent and hypotenuse so what is it in
this case it's just cause cause of that
is gonna be 3/5 and then you don't so I
guess what you could write over here is
I think sohcahtoa is fine
if you want a bit of any tape between
yourself of how you write that you can
say for example because beta equals
adjacent over hypotenuse in this case
that's so that's what it looks like but
this is really what way you do okay
let's keep on going down I can use the
sine rule to find out Amos - do you
remember that there was a problem with
it
sometimes it's this angle and acute
angle sometimes it's that one it's
obtuse but they will tell you what kind
of information will you need to use the
sine room
yeah Nick what German right over here
yeah when you do a minute yeah good so
I'm gonna take this and turn it upside
down yeah like that good people's okay
so it's the same familiar sign well just
flip it upside down now the great thing
you're writing that first is actually
answered this question for you if what
you're trying to find is this guy what
are you going to need in order to find
it what kind of information in the
Triangle yeah you need this angle right
and two sides that have opposite those
angles okay so instead of saying a side
and to matching angles I'm gonna say an
angle and two matching sides
okay normos their last line there is one
more way to find an angle in a triangle
if you know every side that's there so
if you know all three sides what am I
going to use yeah the cosine rule if my
one of my angles starts with because
because I brought cos cos C equals good
okay now because we're only reading that
these last week I won't be surprised if
you like okay I sort of recognize it but
I do not remember it just yet and that's
okay it's kind of the reason why the
formula and data sheet is there however
I hope you say to say oh okay this all
fits into a scheme depending on what I
want and what I've got I now have all of
these different tools that I can use
okay now actually before to open up 5g
so do that now question
yep yeah that's exactly right the
trickiest thing with this guy over here
is okay which angle do you want and
therefore you've gotta be careful with
this guy you see how he's different to
everything else I can swap Amy I can for
my main man but see is different so for
instance I said here if I've got 12 13
14 yes that's so in fact that's one of
the questions if you happen on if I said
to you can you tell me let's write let's
do it the other way can you tell me
what's the size of the biggest day over
here okay the really long way to do this
is to say well let's just find all the
angles and find out which one looking at
the size of each one okay but instead
you can know remember that the bigger
the angle gets the bigger the opposite
side gets yes
so which angle do I want which angle
will be the biggest the one opposite the
biggest suicide let's go back young
right so I guess in that case you have
to write this down because it's nice and
then they believe it's called Theia
constant theater is going to be twice
width plus 13 squared - what do you see
that's the biggest side so that's why it
makes it easy and perfect exactly right
and then 2 times 12 times 13 and then
don't forget to press shift cause ya
know and you can see it doesn't matter
which one and B if you just have a look
and say you accidentally wrote them the
other way around if I read this is 13
squared + 12 square and then read this
is 13 and 12 everything will still be
the same you're still squaring you're
still adding you're still multiplying
all of those are identical only this guy
gets treated different
well if you'll ask for the log if you
answer the biggest angle yeah
then this will be a bit longer so if I
asked you for the smallest angle
how should I read you yeah it will be um
give me this one here winter so that one
is opposite the small sign so I guess
that good 13 squared 14 squared 12
squared that's opposite what I want and
I guess if someone was reading says tell
me the middle angle then you would say
or is it this side
you'll be given all three sides so you
can always work out which one is rich
just read carefully what they're asking